being a great Storyteller is extremely
powerful in terms of keeping people's
attention the first seconds of your
video are so unbelievably important in
terms of like delivering on that value
proposition in some way or giving the
audience a reason to continue to watch
one of the kind of tactics and I think
it's kind of a basic tactic is to
essentially repeat the title okay uh at
the beginning of the video that
essentially lets the viewer know that
they're in the right
place so what does it actually take to
grab viewer attention in today's world
with your video content I'm excited for
this conversation on the think media
podcast today with Matt gilan who's the
CEO and co-founder of electric monster
as well as little monster media Co
really on my radar you blew up with
multiple articles on like cracking the
YouTube algorithm years ago and uh you
just got done speaking here on the video
intro is out say hello to video starts
so what's the difference between a video
intro and a video start but before we
get get there for people that are just
meeting you break down who you are a
little bit about what it is you do thank
you very much for having me on um so
little monster is an agency I started
about six years ago to help uh video
Publishers build their audiences
primarily on YouTube and the way I was
able to grow that agency was through
things like writing those uh papers and
Publishing them on two filter as well as
speaking at events like VidCon about you
know what we know about the
recommendation system and audiences on
YouTube and and how to really uh get the
most out of that and then about uh 3
years or so two and a half years or so
ago I started electric monster with a
couple of other guys uh raised a little
bit of money we started acquiring
YouTube channels our biggest acquisition
to date as the former fbe Brands react
and people verse food uh we're currently
operating those and and kind of uh
evolving those into 2023 and Beyond wow
so you're really like a YouTube secret
weapon you geek out on like the
analytics the backend optimizing content
performing content you also can discern
content that sucks and you kind of know
why it sucks and you improve it um like
one of things one of the things you just
did is you were talking about you
basically revive these you're kind of
acquiring channels and maybe Reviving
them as well or taking them to the next
level but let's break down this uh talk
you just did what's the difference
between a video intro and a video start
yeah so really nothing and I wrote the
title of the presentation and I hate it
okay but the the reason we did that is
that this uh was actually two
presentations that we did internally for
our team at electric monster when you
know we acquired react and and coming
into this year we took a a really hard
look at our retention curves and what we
found was we were losing a lot of
audience early on and what we found with
the beginnings of our videos is they
were very very hit oriss some of them
were really good and some of them were
really poor and in this presentation I
showed an example of probably one of our
worst ones uh and then an example of
after we kind of went through the
training and the analysis what they
started to look like and um you know as
as you've seen in some of my previous
work like the taxonomy I need things
categorized and understandable and
labeled right and so what I recognized
when we were talking about intro a lot
of our producers had a very set thing in
their mind same thing with the editors
and so I was like well the first thing
we need to do is just let's not call it
an intro anymore right let's call it a
video start right because about starting
the video not introducing the video and
I think there was a lot of you know uh
definition wrapped up in intro that we
could kind of start with a blank state
uh a blank slate with video starts right
so I was like all right let's rename it
and I think video Start is a terrible
name it's too it's too too many words
right like intro is fantastic but we got
to change it so I'm I'm open to other
terms but regardless the the basic
concept is like when someone clicks on a
title and a thumbnail right there's a a
value proposition that is being served
to them right like what the video is
about what they're going to see they're
buying essentially into the the subject
of your video and then you have to
deliver on that and so how the the first
seconds of your video are so
unbelievably important in terms of like
delivering on that value proposition in
some way or giving the reason or giving
the audience a reason to continue to
watch right because we there's so much
content out there there's so many
choices out there's so much things that
they could watch that it's imperative
that we pay hyper close attention to
those first seconds as people are making
that decision uh whether or not to stay
or leave and so to recap a little as
well your title and your thumbnail have
already done quite a bit of heavy
lifting they've already set the context
they've communicated a lot a mistake
would be just simply repeating that um
not necessarily um so what we're talking
about is uh VOD content right content
that someone chooses to to click on and
watch it is very very similar to like
feed based content and autoplay based
content which is usually seen as like
short form or vertical video which is
comes uh later in the presentation we
actually kind of dive into that quite a
bit um but one of the kind of tactics
and I think it's kind of a basic tactic
is to essentially repeat the title uh at
the beginning of the video uh maybe you
restate it in a slightly different way
maybe you've titled it slightly
different than how you actually recorded
it um but that essentially lets the
viewer know that they're in the right
place and lots of viewers probably click
on the thumbnail without having read the
title just cuz it looks cool right or
maybe they forgot what the title was or
what the thumbnail was because they were
served an ad right so restating it and
letting people know that they're in the
right place like you don't want to dwell
on it right you've got only a few
seconds there but sometimes that's okay
because they're like verifying that
they're getting what they clicked on
like how many times do you get something
uh maybe you buy it online you open up
the package to verify it is what it is
right and you see you see all those
videos all the time there's like this is
what I ordered this is what I got it's
like a Mini piano yeah right and they
thought they were ordering a real piano
and so it's that human nature like
especially I think in America like we've
been you know duped by marketers so many
times that kind of the first thing you
have to do is actually like you're in
the right place it's safe you're getting
what you were promised okay what are
some of the other tactics you would
teach for video starts so the kind of
the restating the title or the value
proposition we basically say it's like a
restate and go right uh Sniper Wolf and
uh Dr Mike or are have great examples on
their channels of this where they're
like today we're looking at the you know
50 funniest videos in the world and then
they cut in right and they're just
they're in and you're in the video right
but they verified that you what you've
clicked on is what you're getting one
that we kind of prefer at react is what
we call like a correlated open right
where if we say okay this is '90s hipop
trivia the beginning of the video might
be a really fun fact about like De La
Soul right where someone be like did you
know that de Soul blah blah blah blah
blah right so we're correlating the
value proposition of the title and
thumbnail to the content that you see on
screen we don't have to sit there and go
you're watching you know '90s trivia
onreact right it's kind of a boring
opening for the content that we make and
so correlating it with something that
very clearly shows them they're getting
9s hip-hop trivia um is it works for us
and works for our audience another kind
of strategy that we saw this was on um I
believe it's how ridiculous the
Australian guys or whatever yeah um they
they have this really
interesting uh tactic they Ed that was
uh essentially um a first segment opener
where they basically just begin the
first segment of their video and kind of
go through what would normally be in an
intro in that first segment so the title
and thumbnail and the example we gave in
the presentation was uh our giant axe
cuts a Tesla in half right and when the
video starts right you see this giant
Axe and they go three two one and then
the the guys come on and they're like
today we're going to see you know what
our giant Axe can cut through or not cut
through and then they show it you know
working stuff and it cuts back to them
but you know we're also going to be
gambling on whether or not it'll go
through right and then you see another
little bit and then they're like and the
loser is going to have to do a punish
right and then you see the act like chop
a fire extinguisher in half and like
essentially if they come on and said
today we're going to cut a bunch of
things in half we're going to bet on
whether it'll work or not and then if
you lose you're going to have to face a
punishment then they would go into
cutting the fire extinguish nap that's a
slower opening right so this was very
exciting very high-paced you set up the
rules of the video you explain to them
you know uh what's going on what they're
going to see right while also
simultaneously progressing the story um
and then the final one was one by Ryan
Tran which we called the SE opener um
and it's his uh I built a tiny universe
video um and I won't spoil it for anyone
go watch it Ryan Tran's did an amazing
job on that video in terms of starting
it uh and it's really really cool to see
so that's amazing the value prop of your
session was not just tactics to hook
audiences but also to keep them watching
what are some things you've been
learning once you've gotten them past
that opening uh segment to actually
retain that viewership yeah a great
question I mean I think one of the
things we see uh that's specific to our
type of content uh specifically is that
uh we really want to keep our segments
beneath two minutes right so if we're
doing a '90s Trivia video right we want
to do you know at least 10 to 15 rounds
in a 20- minute long video so a segment
versus the video itself so a segment
means it's just switching up long forms
20 minute total but a segment is two
right and by defining a segment what are
two different segments yeah so um one
would be like what was the number one
billboard single in 1990 and you play
them like 2 seconds of sound or you show
them a picture of a music video and then
for 2 minutes different people react to
that exactly's Swit right and then once
they've all kind of given their answer
and you reveal if they're right or not
right then you go to the next question
right and that would be like the second
segment essentially uh and so like
keeping those segments you know pretty
tight you know from an edit pacing
standpoint like not a tremendous amount
new Under the Sun for you know digital
video right like you remove the breaths
um to to ensure that there's not an
opportunity for the audience to kind of
get distracted and and look at the next
thing yeah um you know there's a concept
that I'm I'm sure you've talked about
before Roberto Blakes talked about it
but like the pattern interrupts right so
if you're on kind of a consistent Pace
like you change something up with like
Motion Graphics all sorts of different
tactics and Motion Graphics all sorts of
different tactics with sound effects and
music and bringing things in and out
right um you know zooming in zooming out
right camera shifts camera pans like our
setup is essentially this it's a camera
on sticks and two people talking yeah
right it is hard to keep that engaging
um without employing a lot of that kind
of like film Mak tactics we've also
started trying to implement a bit more
story into what we do so if we're doing
a Trivia video like we'll try to lead it
with a couple sentences giving a story
about the trivia question um which is a
phenomenal way to keep people engaged
and and a big portion of the
presentation on short form content was
spent uh discussing story and story
structures uh and and um you know from a
viewership perspective being a great
Storyteller um is uh extremely powerful
in terms of keeping people's attention
powerful tips there you know one of your
unique opportunities you have and kind
of Vantage points that you have is your
Viewpoint of the crater economy itself
uh you were just sharing we're here at
VidCon
2023 and what's actually wild is the
landscape is really shifted you run two
agencies two companies it's kind of
Carnage out here a lot of companies have
have are gone since the pandemic um and
so I'm curious your uh a two-prong
question what is the stateof the creater
economy from the company level the the
companies that are being funded the
startups level and all of that but then
also the Creator level the opportunity
uh we've been hanging out at VidCon for
years you know uh video influencers days
Benji and and it's been you've been in
the game even longer than that and we're
kind of in a whole new era and coling
just called it the new wave of creators
so so what do you as a strategist and as
someone who thinks deeply and is in this
what do you see for the future for those
two different tracks kind of two
different opportunities in the Creator
economy or maybe landmines that could be
coming up as well yeah I mean that's a
that's a very big question right um you
know in in terms of the opportunity I
think it's never been greater for
creators right like you can create a
business from scratch with you know next
to no money or zero money really y um
and you know create a extremely
successful small medium large business
right there's all sorts of opportunity
for that and that's from entertainment
content to utility content uh across the
board um and that opportunity exists
both on and off those platforms and that
information especially on channels like
yours is free and available uh at the
very least to take you to kind of like
the first level um of uh developing a
successful business so I think from like
that perspective is extremely valuable
or or there's tremendous opportunity um
the fact that all these platforms are
monetizing content at this point right
Tik tok's monetizing maybe it's not
great but it's coming along right
YouTube and YouTube shorts
monetizing uh reals on Instagram and
Facebook you know snap partner program
this wasn't available 5 years ago it was
basically YouTube right um
you know beyond that all of the the
companies that have come about that
enable the um you know creation of you
know uh creating print on demand
products or developing a um class uh or
or courses online these are all ways uh
to you know monetize that content if
that's your your goal and pursuit um on
the opposite side I think there's a lot
of macroeconomic factors that are very
disruptive right now and and there's a
lot that maybe they're coming maybe
they're not but I think we've seen
generally speaking somewhere in the
range of uh a reduction in 10 to 20%
year-over-year um in RPMs just because
advertisers aren't spending as much
because of a theoretical pending
recession uh maybe we are in a recession
a rolling recession like no one really
knows and there's a lot of like I think
fear and doubt and apprehension um you
know advertising budgets are usually the
first things that dry up in a recession
right and that's already happened it's
been happening for the past year so if
there is some sort of like big event I
think it's going to be more like that Co
event where like RPMs dropped for 8
weeks right and then we've had the
greatest RPM expansion ever uh in the
you know months that followed uh right
after you know the initial Co lockdown
so you I think there's a world of
opportunity out there for for creators
by way of Industry um you know where
where it generally stands is that
there's very few kind of like digital
media companies um outside of
creator-driven companies um you know I I
run
one of like very few that do that uh and
it's it's difficult right people
gravitate to personalities and and
characters and form
relationships um with that person on
screen we'll see more of that come about
uh potentially in the next you know two
three four years as more money kind of
comes into the industry and um can do a
combination of both working in you know
digital media versus Creator um or you
know providing more support into
creators and investing in creators which
is something that we're just starting to
see like there was you know a few
companies here that um you know take
Equity positions uh in Creator
businesses help them scale up their
businesses and you know then there's
something like electric monster that
would do um you know a a full
acquisition kind of scenario so there's
a tremendous amount of opportunity a lot
of fear but uh that's a a great time to
be opportunistic and and uh you know
really double down wow yeah and so it
sounds like a ton of opportunity for
creators cuz they're also so often times
bootstrapped and so lean some
recessionary factors that have disrupted
in the pandemic that disrupted the
businesses but yeah you also mentioned
and some of the other interviews we had
Silicone Valley girl being one uh raised
raised vent raised Capital just as a
creater um and so that I think is an
expanding era that we're in and you
mentioned the fact that maybe even in
the Landscapes here's kind of changed
but for the first time ever you saw VCS
walking around and and that would and
what do that if you broke that down
though to not a lot of people talking
about VCS at the average K kitchen table
if you're not on like you know in
Silicone Valley or here what does that
actually you think it'll mean as it
translates out over the next 12 to 24
months yeah it's a great question I mean
and and I should be uh honest like uh
I'm I'm very new to kind of the
financial side of this because little
monster was a bootstrap company yeah
right at electric monster I had
co-founders who handled uh most of that
uh early on and so um I'm I'm kind of
learning it uh myself as well I would
say like you know VCS being here VCS
traditionally are investing in the kind
of picks and shovels right these are
like technology plays that are scalable
that um you know can um you know uh
bring it in you know tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands millions of users
to use that product um where that
initial investment gets paid off
significantly down the road when you're
able to reach that amount of Market um
what we're seeing with um our industry
is that there are also VCS that are um
you know investing at in non- Tech and
non kind of picks and shovels not the
tech tools investing in directly into
creators where people some creators have
um transition themselves into a brand in
and of themselves and a brand is just
another word for a company right where
they have a team supporting them and
surrounding them and that Capital can be
used to do things like hire more editors
make more content set up a shop license
content uh create a merchandising line
uh all sorts of different ways to scale
up that business and um you know that's
a that's a traditional model right
that's uh Rees Witherspoon doing hello
sunshine that's the Honis Co with um is
it Jessica Alba hco right it's it's
leveraging your reach and forgive me
influence to build a business and and
brand and people are finally recognizing
like oh that's what creators are
creators are celebrities and some of
them just want to be celebrities and
just want to be famous and and that's
fine right some of them want to build
sustainable long-term businesses or
build intergenerational wealth and you
know I think VCS and private Equity
firms have recognize that uh and can
come in and provide that Capital that'll
either help that Creator grow or allow
that Creator to exit that business that
they have built yeah very interesting
time that we're living in as we land the
plane on one kind of topic that a lot of
people our community feel like there's
mystery around and that is um creating
kids content I think uh you know ever
since Kaa and it feeling now you check
in a box is this made for kids is it not
made for kids people wonder about
monetization um I didn't even know about
certain RPMs YouTube kids app versus the
main app um and you've you run a couple
kids channels and so you've got
experience here in doing it in a
sustainable way first of all speak to us
like fifth grade reading level about the
approach and the strategy and the upside
and the challenges because I think also
as you tiptoe in like oh I can't do
affiliate marketing to kids I can't like
put certain ads you know Amazon's terms
of service for example uh and that's one
of the things we talk a lot about so at
the same time it's a very legitimate
more than legitimate like there's
massive success as kids content creators
or you know content creator for children
so what are what's kind of the model
what would be the approach what are the
opportunities and what are the things
you can't do um if somebody wanted to
launch a channel directed at kids oh
that's a that's a big question I mean um
starting from the top down I mean Moon
bug sold for 2.7 billion to Candle media
and moon bug is a company that bought
Coco melon and blippy and uh little baby
Bomb and several other big channels uh
in the the kids space you know from a
monetization perspective like you're
generally making um you know at the high
end maybe 25 cents uh per thousand views
out of uh kids content which is a blend
of both kids app viewership and YouTube
main viewership that's both combined
yeah I mean give or take I mean that's
kind of on the lower end um you know
some of our kids properties get you know
above into the one two three range
depending on the average view duration
the mix of views from kids app versus uh
YouTube Main and then also the topic of
the video right like more educational
based content is is going to outperform
like nursery rhyme because there's such
a massive volume of viewership for
nursery rhyme that there's so much
inventory and there's just not as much
of a demand for it um in terms of like
things you can and cannot do I don't
think I'm I'm going to say anything
other than like kind of what's in the
YouTube terms of service which like if
you're making kids content you should
probably be able to follow anyway right
they're not that Draconian in nature but
it's like basically don't advertise to
kids please you know other than and
stuff that's been vetted by our team
right because those are the only ads
that will be served on kids content that
is labeled as made for kids is content
that's been reviewed by a human and
determined to be within the brand
guidelines of made for kids and that's
not you you're just checking the box and
letting YouTube handle that correct yeah
and so does Ryan toy reviews advertis in
his content though well I mean it
depends on what you mean by
advertisement so I was having a yeah
right um so I was having a debate with
someone and they were talking about like
the their app it was a kid focus app
like oh yeah we don't want to have
products you you know no toys and we
want to have this vertical which is
science and learning and this one that's
about like your body and health and
we're going to have a gaming verticle
and I was like let me stop you right
there right because a gaming video is
literally playing with a toy for the
entire video right like what do you
think a video game is it's the game
itself that you would purchase out the
app store or in app purchases you get
downloads yeah exactly and so like you
know they kind of like hedged and we
like well you know it's gaming content
so whatever right and it's it's kind of
like this weird subjective line right of
what is or is not safe for kids at a
macro level and then what is or is not
safe for your kids right I think
generally speaking YouTube within the
kids app does a pretty good job they're
not perfect no one is world's biggest
platform you know trillions of views you
know lots and lots of you know people
uploading and by far the vast majority
just want to make cool stuff that people
enjoy but you know anytime you know
there's a there's a party that's massive
someone wants to come along and ruin it
right um and people have ruined the
YouTube kids experience multiple times
in the past and so like you know it is
it is restrictive your content's not
going to show up in the kids app for
sometimes weeks um until it's been
reviewed by a human but uh in an effort
to keep kids safe and protect the
industry and make sure advertisers
aren't afraid to advertise within
YouTube kids and parents aren't afraid
to put the YouTube kids app in front of
their kids um you know it's it's what's
got to be done so like there are some
restrictions but generally speaking it's
going to be fine what kind of numbers if
if you know the math off the top of your
head when I think about blippy these
days and now as a dad of a two and a
halfy old and 9month old this is why I'm
now the most educated connoisseur of
kids K I never even watched it before
and now I'm like a blippy expert and Ma
and the fake B blippy second actor he's
at scale but it's actually a pretty cool
story because he started super simple
and and had to build up everybody
started at zero I think that for some
kids channels I think it's kind of an
uphill battle but it would seem at RPMs
of those numbers and the inability to
advertise that you you could just do the
math you'd say okay if I wanted to do
this like full let's say I want to work
back from Mak it a sixf fig business
because I want to have a couple
Freelancers helping me I want to film
and then I could pay my bills and I
could maybe do that at like 100k then if
I'm doing the views play then I need to
calculate the math that I need millions
of views oh uh for sure well if you're
getting a $1 RPM right you need million
monthly views 100 million monthly right
because that'll give you wait that's
100K a month would that' be 100K a month
so if you got 100 million views in a
year at a $1 RPM then you'd make
$100,000 in a year right and but if
you're at a 25 cent RPM then you 400
million yeah you need half a trillion
and that that would be on long form yeah
exactly is short form even relevant for
kids yeah they're a lot of short form in
the kids app they're they're very uh
bullish on that and pushing that um but
that would also be would it be similar
to the YouTube shorts I've seen get
about 2 4 six maybe 9 Cent RPMs on a for
adults yeah that I mean you're not mon
you're you can write off the
monetization for shorts and kids
basically there is some but it's like a
fraction of a fraction yeah exactly it's
it's impossible without being like
family vloggers to create a sustainable
kids content business on YouTube in in
my view pretty much anywhere else right
unless your pitching Studios who are
going to finance it da da like if you
want to be a video Creator on YouTube
and you're not like a family Vlog
probably not going to make it on YouTube
unless you're willing to lose lots and
lots and lots of money up front as
you're scaling up to 400 and and and for
a at scale organization 6 fig is not
even a ton of money if you have it's you
know but if so so the solo Creator
though could work back from that math
what kind of content could I create that
would get 400 million views a year
that's it's like lottery ticket sure
style right like it's just it's not an
environment where that's going to happen
now the immediate kind I thought after
that like well what if you can layer in
licensing and syndication and
merchandise and that sort of thing it's
like well what individual has that skill
set or the time sure to do that right if
you're trying to put together like a 20
minute you know video a week you're a
single entrepreneur it's just not
realistic unless you're like family
vloggers got it right um you're not
going to animate that much that fast
right like you're just not going to you
know cast people or hire like it's just
not realistic in the kids space I will
it's is interesting and I don't know
their uh name off the top but they came
up to me they actually were a part of
our community they've been watch it for
years they are creating VR content
they've created a character they film it
in the VR world and edit it in like
Premiere um and they said they're more
like teen audience uh and kind kind of
maybe like Chad wal clay which I think
Their audience is aged up a little bit
maybe or is that kids
content that's not family vlogging I
mean it's well it's definitely not
family vlogging I think they make
interesting stories um you know it's
it's an example I often give when I talk
about like one of the first successful
narrative you know web series um and
they blend it with all these other
formats it's brilliant I love Chad and I
love v um but I think there are
audiences from Age 4 to 18 that can
enjoy what they're doing yeah um and so
like I don't think they make it
specifically for kids right they don't
necessarily often feature or or ever
from what I've seen like toys or
products that are aimed at kids they
don't necessarily like speak to kids or
uh and there's no kids in their content
right they're what probably in their 30s
at this point um so like no I think it's
I think they make content for a wide age
group um that uh you know isn't
necessarily made for kids so that could
be the approach there if they're not
checking the box but can that content
find its way to the kids app yeah um in
in two kind of ways actually um one
would be like YouTube reviews the
content and decides that it's made for
kids yeah um which I have all sorts of
not sa for work thoughts and opinions on
that dichotomy but um the second way is
um YouTube Just sees that the content is
popular with that age group and puts it
in there um one example I heard them
give was like well baseball highlights
right there's lots of kids on the kids
app they love watching baseball right so
you know the baseball highlights most of
them are safe for work right and so they
put them in the kids app and kids enjoy
watching them okay so just in recap for
kids creators and aspiring kids creators
that's going to be a tough model to get
a su in the crater economy if you need
to even get enough views if you're check
in the box and content is just for kids
however if you're a family
vlogger um then that is the exception
and then there's also this kind of line
of maybe you're there's lots of content
formats that might be interesting to
kids but you're not checking the box
they're not directed to kids it might be
very popular there and so very
interesting um and has has story book
content made it very far what is story
book uh people reading uh reading books
and I think it's a copywritten issue too
sometimes but they just yeah they just
go for it and they just read a kids book
I mean I have I've never seen that
content or channels that feature that
content be successful sure like I think
it's maybe you're getting thousands of
views but that's the problem it's not
going to reach the scale that you need
yeah and you know that could be a
situation where like it's not
necessarily like about scale or about
making the AdSense Revenue but it's
about like you know advertising the
books and so parents go out and buy the
books yeah you yeah you are a kids's
author and you and then you're you have
a whole Amazon Play right but even then
right like let's say you get 10,000
views uh let's say 5,000 of them are in
the US right what portion of them are
actually going to go and buy that book
when they know they can just watch you
read it if you read the whole thing
right or and what portion of them liked
it liked it enough to go and you know
spend the 15 20 bucks or whatever it is
right uh or yeah if the parents even
recognize that it's being watched or
hear it um so it's tough It's real real
tough you got to get a massive scale
Matt you've shared a lot of value about
multiple topics today I really
appreciate it if people want to check
out what you're doing um what kind of
stuff can what where can they follow you
and keep up with you yeah I mean the
best place to follow me is LinkedIn uh I
say at our uh Creator convention uh
focused on YouTube uh to be to be
perfectly honest that's where I share
all kind of the professional stuff and
and links to stuff um like the stuff I
write for two filter so that's probably
the best place awesome appreciate you so
much thanks for adding value to the
think media podcast
uh subscribe if you're not subscribed
share this episode with somebody that
maybe would find it interesting like and
leave a comment if you're on YouTube and
let us know your thoughts and rate and
review if you're on audio appreciate you
Sean canel think media podcast